the beauty of kawaii just fills my soul
there are places of extreme beauty
and that for me is the Napali Coast
where there's a hidden gem an old
village site called NOLA loci
[Music]
it is an absolutely ideal place to
perpetuate Hawaiian culture
[Music]
like even like I teach Hawaiian studies
here in Hawaii and the children call me
kou moukaku I teach hula which is
Hawaiian dance
oh hello Hawaii which is Hawaiian
language and copper which is Hawaiian
part class oh my god it's so beautiful
in Hawaii we did not have loomed
material we made our clothing and our
blankets from the bark of a tree kava is
made first by growing the plant and then
harvesting it scraping off the outer
bark removing the inner bark and
pounding it out you've got a pound and
pound and pound and pound and then you
need many many strips and you felt them
together and pound them all out as one
but you've got to have the materials to
teach Hawaiian arts and those materials
are very much based on plants
[Applause]
you have to grow the Vulcan order to
make copper that's why we have been
returning to NOLA loci for 27 years
there are no roads in there it's only
accessible by boat or by air
[Music]
you feel the sense of place when you
land then you walk along the little
trail and when you look out at the ocean
and you see the turtles that are resting
on the beach they have been on that
Beach for centuries we have only been on
that Beach more recently
our first trip into Nuala loci was to
return ancestral remains or coupon evey
and ever since that trip we have been
going back to take care of this old
village site and we have also planted
bulky there to make cuppa and I'm so
trying to figure out how my kupuna how
my ancestors made it as beautifully as
they have it's a process we have to
relearn these things
so it's a place of old Hawaii that
brings much to our understanding of
perhaps how life used to be I like to
teach my children about kapa because
first of all they have to learn how to
take care of the plants and then they
have to learn how to harvest them and
how to clean them and how to pound them
[Music]
they know who they are they know where
they live
you know why they live here and what
they can do to help how do Hawaiians see
the land that the land is the chief and
that people are its servants
[Music]